hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to this nightmare now
we got screwed over just a little bit by
who I now know is the janitor and I'm
just guessing that the janitors job is
to clean up the mess left behind by her
one and no not this time no no no no you
did create no that is not me stop
grabbing the pipe like that hi okay well
eight is the commander knew maybe if I
Imperials neeki beat you once you grab
that pipe I'm gonna go for oh yeah that
like that if I made me then anybody
booze any me no don't even try
alright radhika's you're gonna have to
take the bait for me on this one and
just you know take one for the team here
because I'd like to think that we're all
cooperating in the attempt to not die or
those who feel that are those bags
filled with okay I thought you know I
thought there was a possibility you
weren't gonna do that I thought that I
would have a chance to not be
instantaneously killed not ago
[Music]
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah okay all right
open a book bootable oh wow wow you got
some reach on you
holy [ __ ] holy [ __ ] you got some reach
on you okay so what I got to do know I'm
up here I don't know what I'm supposed
to be doing
oh that thing is still rushing brick
crack the left there's got to be a way
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa okay so
there's gotta be a way maybe I could oh
no you want me this
that might be the thing maybe it wants
me to try to to like it might build this
might be a little Brodie but oh no I
thought I could grab a little more but
you grabbed me instead so this is like a
boss fight oh so I've got a dude not
today not today not today are you going
where you going with your hands there
okay no ah goddamn he didn't happy and
then I thought he had me and then he
didn't at me so I know what it's like a
boss fight probably rule of three six oh
yeah yeah yeah no no don't even bother
trying to grab that and then boil well
god damn it ah man this is brutal it's
brutal but I'm gonna get you okay I got
one I got one I got one I'm going foot
to foot Gopal real to foodie so I got to
make make sure the Topher Grace over
there doesn't grab on to what he doesn't
need to grab on to
[Music]
girl oh geez oh man the one thing that
guy had going for him was his arms and
now he's just got his stubby legs and
nothing to show for it so ha I stopped
right before the boss battle didn't I
should have gone just a little bit
farther last time but you live and you
learn
oh I got an achievement I unlocked it I
finished the lair I wasn't that close
and sorry guys but carrying on that was
oh I'm okay whatever you say buddy boo
whatever you say
poor guy I mean one he's gonna die
obviously because probably incredible
blood loss was going to get to him
eventually but boy howdy that's does it
does a bad way to go after a little
little tiny creature and then you end up
with that happenin to you I would go for
a ride oh I thought it was gonna grab on
to the look can I go out here there's
some out here like whoa whoa such a dick
okay do I want to do Oh
oh god oh god oh god I'm gonna grab on
to that I think okay I didn't do that
apparently it's like crap I don't quit
where am I where am I
can you just make up your goddamn where
am i okay first off we're and second off
what to to get dinged up now
you [ __ ] why'd you do that
I guess no one expected them to die here
because why would they have not my fault
not my fault that 100% not my fault I
don't know what you guys talk about I am
good at games and I know exactly what
I'm doing when I'm playing them okay so
stop being a big dumb dumb doof and I'm
gonna jump onto these actually correctly
this time no there we go okay grabbed on
I don't know if there's what I was
supposed to do but I'm gonna do it
anyway because it feels right I'm
following a body boom you fell down why
you fall down oh I could have grabbed on
here I could have cracked on over here
ha ha ha oh oh hi ah this is where all
the quote/unquote meat goes but you know
one thing I will say these these bags
they look distinctly oh don't know
follow these bags look distinctly not
childlike so I'm wondering what is the
point of all this
no honey why does it wise to kick it so
hungry but do you get so angry so often
don't know it's not good why so often oh
no no oh oh no
Oh No ah okay I don't know if there was
another option for that I guess I would
just drink its blood that's all I needed
okay I guess I'm fine then all right
well that was an event
I guess I'm fine for now then get better
thing I don't know how much time has
passed so I guess I guess I can't
exactly say that this kid is getting
super hungry super fast because honestly
how would I know that I don't finish you
haha I know how physics works so I I'm
not supported by your puzzles here game
I think I have an inkling to my gamer
instinct to know exactly what to do when
I needs to do it so some hello okay
[Music]
okay meet Jim uh I could have waited
until I got here when there's oodles and
Kaboodle's of food this is nothing but
food tonight why did I settle the
question here was that you know what no
by the corner I can't see oh god oh god
oh god oh god right into the pot Hey ah
thank you for that I can't see when
doorway is blocking me what do you want
from me I was trying to go here I saw
this the first time oh okay all right
then
yeah keep slicing BIOS in the hole
what's with your face what is wrong with
you
wait what wait he's wearing a mask wait
I'm not that's not just his bulbous fat
maybe it's his bulbous fat maybe I'm
wrong about that it seemed to me like he
might have just been I don't know seemed
like he might have been wearing a mask
on the back of that but I'm not a
hundred percent sure cool hi yeah under
hard don't worry about me it looks like
a mask what no it can't be no no that's
the way the graphics are this is so
bizarre are you doing over there
all right here I go I guess remind me
oh I'm skedaddle with you I guess no
didn't mean to do that did not mean to
do that
that's right that's what I thought
there's nothing over there you're you're
real dumb you know that yeah that's what
I thought who's super stupid
ketotic the worst kitchen I've ever seen
doodly-doo doodly-doo doodly-doo oopsy
poopsy arms yeah were you doing there
buddy huh
having trouble breathing you get some
spices to go
you didn't hear nothin gonna keep on
here you can't see nothing going down
gold I would dad today where am i where
am I not going why am I not going where
am I and why am i not going I can't see
myself
I'm Ina goddamn well I guess I'm gonna
stay here for a little bit longer
because apparently I can't frickin move
okay but now how about now can we go now
there we go this game this game huh did
we do a boobity boo I'm gonna climb up
there then get to push out of here
barbra dude we didn't know you you can't
see me can you no no no no no no no I
meant to run that oh god oh god oh god
oh you can't do that you don't know
where I am do you
well they didn't pose exactly where I am
I'll give up all kinds got a freaking
fish mouth no cheese yaar anybody would
Wow oh how did you hang these up here
they seemed like they were there a long
arm job if you know me do these even get
up here who gets these supplies are
these fish not rotting horribly Oh weird
all right I guess we're just gonna climb
a wall up fish you know I ate a live rat
and if I had waited just one more second
I would have been utterly fine out of an
honky and durian why don't I always end
up in toilets why do I always end up in
toilet I don't have a control okay hello
ah I'm in a lovely mood what was that
hello are you gonna lead me to a secret
or is this gonna be you know London Oh
tippy tappy tippy-toe II the deputy pedo
II do we do no oh sleeping on the job
are we oh I see a shadow
I see you I see you
ah habit Debus good oh no no it's not
time for wakey wakey eggs and Bakey it
it's not time for that at all
oh you didn't see nothing Oh what is
with that picture
are they brothers oh I don't like the
new brother your brothers bad brother
here we go I think I need to do this
grab that and then I'm gonna gently set
it over there okay hey cuz I'm so smart
gently set that there and then I'm gonna
swing swung the one time this is gonna
work right
Oh grab it [ __ ] you you son of I know
that's what I was supposed to do oh I
can just climb up here okay that's good
oh it's cool Oh hold ink okay well I got
a key now so that's handy huh buddy haha
lucky I've got a key down I'm going over
here now buddy
but here's Liddy but but me but I got a
key hood Liddy oh this is okay oh please
tell me that guy's not taking a massive
dump is that what the logics oh good I
was worried that he was going to be
digging a massive jump no no no pick
that back up please and let it skedaddle
down to the other place wherever the
hell we're supposed to go oh there was a
key downstairs every
oh it's pressure sensitive for some
reason hello again
where you skedaddling off dude let's get
ahead lady but allah dhu gonna see if
there's something over here and help no
you know boys quick wait what are you
doing it's very clearly a Joker's bus in
earth it's right there oh oh oh no no no
this is that jar don't mind me just that
jar it's weird huh
weird out our jars jingle-jangle
aluminum.aluminum yeah you know the
second time you just look stupid when
you don't find what was making the noise
idiot I don't know if there's a way to
open this jar or not but it seems like
it might be a negative because I don't
think I just don't think it's gonna let
me pick it up oh it never mind
hey ah your hiding space has been
spoiled you better run you better run
dude you better you better run you had
best run bra bra bra bra where you going
oh wow good hiding spot breath you are
just the sneakers
hmm shouldn't be coughing and other
people's foods dude put you're not about
health of standards okay so what do I
say about you guys you do what today
did I just hug it or did i strangle it
okay I think I hugged it I'm not well I
have I suppose was I supposed to be
doing that again I don't know do you
sneak on you again
sneaky sneaky sneaky you okay oh good
that was a close one
good thing I went for that Oh get your
disgusting hands off of that stuff no
girls okay dee Liddy a deal Eddie make
my way over here with my key I'll be
diddly deee he but really do I let B not
be Talib oh I wish I was faster daddy oh
hey you didn't see that yeah frickin
weirdo yeah go dingle-dangle over there
but no did you see oh ho ho
all open run run run run run run run run
run we're fine
fine fine yeah we're fine we're fine huh
good okay we got that let's go go go go
go do something about it oh you're so
strong
if run run run run run run run run run
run run run run run up here go here
dodge the meat cleaver go over here rub
up here I'm good oh it's not the sausage
making machine oh god that's always
disgusting that is never fun but here we
go apparently
away no I need to fill it with me
because that why Oh what was that
nondescript piece of meat I don't know
here we go apparently
it's always so disgusting okay how many
how many of these bad boys do I need to
make and also why oh do I need more meat
oh okay I see what I need to do maybe I
need to go up and oh I need to make a
sausage train so that I can swing swung
across it oh that's disgusting but all
right you know what I'll play your game
so I got to find something big enough to
dump on that to be able to make and pop
me oh this should be interesting
I don't know what this wants to do who
is that it's another one these dolls so
I guess ah well release that ghost into
the wind glad that happened so what are
those things
lose air-conditioner who you are a big
rat you seem to be feeding on the corpse
of some friend I don't like that but
whoops
never mind I thought I was going to come
confront y'all dynamo style and really
flat do you buddy boo ya know how do I
get up there and I see what I gotta do
oh oh ha ha ha
er girl
gross but it's a big piece of meat and I
do need big pieces of meat I see another
one over on the table over there so I'm
going to get that eventually hey can you
just you know finish the job that you
started here and yeah that's good enough
alright then
did that just move did that just pulsate
living Lee oh oh oh here we go I guess
Podolski right Lulu B huh I don't know
why these are gross these are probably
perfectly fine pieces of choice cut and
prime meat of some sort straight from
the set of higher my ass 100% official
Danny sex bang meat here and yeah gross
okay but maybe that's enough it'll at
least make a few more hot dogs sausages
or whatever you want to call them
definitely not hot dogs but here we go
oh boy
oh thank you what if physics goofed and
gave me the wrong thing there
Oh what does it only make that much meat
all right let's see if that's enough
yeah Wow astonishingly this is the
pinnacle of game design oh boy Oh glad
that happened
all right carrying on lest we find
something less gross got to get the
maximum amount of gross no matter what
we do
oh hello more meat what is all this meat
for that's the one thing that's on my
mind why in the world number one do they
need all this meat and number two where
do they get it like where does this all
come from it could be a situation where
these are like monsters or invaders or
some horrible deformed I have a feeling
something's gonna be coming up with that
oh I was right
oh I was right I was right over and
slide a slide into winner's circle hello
hi oh you're the brother oh you're the
brother what are you doing no stop gross
well that's the bro oh why did you need
to shake that cheese where did you put
that you don't have pockets
all right so am I supposed to try to
make my way down there and what did you
just put in your pocket that doesn't
make any sense all right I'm going to
try to go for this because if I can get
in that elevator before you do I'm gonna
take it I'm gonna take it I'm gonna take
it gbtb2 me buddy pressure-sensitive
Valerie warga knows something's up
oh [ __ ] I don't have anything to throw
at this hill better go through this hole
here how convenient
all right you don't know where I am do
you
oh you can't be me I'm in darkness I'm
like a shadow in the night oh you'll
never know where I am
god you're so creepy what's with your
face what's wrong with your face oh I
swear it just looks like a big-ass mask
why would he be wearing a mask unless
he's trying to look soon unless that
some misguided horrific attempt to look
human and in reality these things aren't
human and they harvest the humans right
am i onto something there and I think I
might be onto something because that
wouldn't make sense because it looked
like the other guy had it still had his
skin Oh Oh [ __ ] gross no no don't do
that don't do that why would they
continue to try to look human those are
obviously not good human heads not not
good on there but there's something to
be said about you so disgusting
please don't do that ever don't do that
ever again good let him
connealy do sneaking my way through your
butt back oh god what what do you what
what is that what is all of that no
don't
can I run for it no need to run for it
time to be sneaky peeky like but I see
the key on the table why did he keep the
key on that table okay you don't need to
be angry about it dude
cool boy I gotta go I gotta go I gotta
go I gotta go
was that I don't know what that means oh
oh she's got showered by that no oh no
no no no no you don't know I am yeah
right
thank you God a mystery it's a cup of
give him frickin victory huh
okay so what was the point of that
can you stick your head in there and
just make my life a lot easier
oh hello lighting seems to be a little
bit weird on you
yeah no I'm not there mi no I'm not
just carry on with your day have a good
one
toodles toodles - Oh toodles to use so I
got to get the key somehow but I just
lost my distraction noise so I gotta
have another way to cause a ruckus of a
distraction can I move one of these pots
a little closer nah
no okay but maybe I can climb up here
and drag another one of these things in
here no I lost my distraction chance so
but there's got to be something else I
can do to make him move away because I
need that key I do I guess I could just
turn it on yeah yeah it doesn't have to
be a baguette there I just need to turn
it off no no no no no you didn't see
anything what are you talking about what
are you talking about wolf will ring
on the road the pocketful of posies [ __ ]
you [ __ ] you oh my god again now alright
but that was the right stratagem I just
didn't go about it the right way so I
just got to be a little less stupid
about it and then I'll be good to go
come on wake up little boy girl I've run
I said efficient not stupid Oh slid into
the winner's circle
alright here we go here we go here we go
point and point and grab it and run run
okay where was I run into again
completely stop was it down here go go
go go now would be the time to go that
would be the time to go you think
they're brothers in competing
restaurants or something like that
an experiment or awesome that I don't
know where I'm going caboose King man
you'll never find huh how this door
mysteriously get opened I don't know oh
gosh anything to my mask alrighty then
yeah yeah oh yeah I'm over there
idiot dummy you're gonna come back
I guess he was just done cooking or
something yeah okay you just take a
breather buddy boo
boink skew yeah that that sounded why am
I going to jump in the trash chute all
right why did I jump there gonna be
another Sarlacc down here huh whoo
plunger I can't use that well nevermind
then I'll just carry on in the garbage
that I love being in here for a Y all up
here okay
Oh where's that oh it's the same believe
he just was I just happened to go in the
garbage just to you know have some fun I
guess oh soap oh I don't know something
else entirely
oh they're working together all their
brothers
look at those broham being weird and
gross and that's a lot of dishes because
they must be feeding a lot of people
people I say more like move so there's
got to be a reason right it has to be a
society right I must be escaping this
horrible horrible version of society
that they have here you know I'm just
gonna go for it sound like they see me
or nothing you can't see me there
distorted no what you see something no
that's a lie no you don't did you see
that breath broer to go oh oh oh I can't
bend down too far breath you gotta help
me out with this bro man that is a lot
efficient I mean you guys do all this I
mean admittedly it's impressive if you
think about it these new guys doing all
this cooking for this amount of dishes
that I mean wow much respect to them
except for the fact that they eat me
good way here we go boink boink well
this is a nod
can you just jump down because they are
coming I heard that oh maybe not
okay can I get over here somehow yeah I
can climb over item / chuckles oh oh oh
oh I will slide into victory you didn't
see nothin did you
Oh what are you gonna do with that play
figure you have amazing grip strength I
don't even have to bend your hand old
welp there goes never mind
I was just complimenting you and then
you proved yourself to be a and
competent goof Oh your face oh I swear I
swear they're aliens it's the only
explanation to all those they're aliens
that is a hundred sir
so there's got to be a way now that
that's activated to climb up and get on
to those hooks ro8 not that way though
it's got to be some other way can you go
around that handle that'd be great
is this so peeing slidy here we go home
oh there's a god Little Italy ding-dong
yeah what do you what do you hear
nothing
Oh weird how much nothing you heard but
either way the hooks must be going up
above so that must mean what you see
nothing oh nothing you do all right good
job you're an incompetent buffoon so
there's gotta be like Oh the plates of
course I can climb up the plays hopeful
I don't knock them over but there's got
to be okay there's got to be one path of
plates you can lead me right up to it in
a queue like it might be that one right
in the center there because there's kind
of a spotlight on it that guy in don't
seem to be vacating his post so let me
just see if there's another one around
here no I am a funny feeling it's going
to be that centre stack of plates
Rory moon ha joke's on him he shouldn't
have moved in my opportunity to shine
that's
can you but maybe I can disturb them oh
oh
Yuri oh you guys are dumb I'm sorry what
do you see a whole lot of nothing
Oh get rag rag bros oh you stupid stupid
on her and why are they so freaked out
by this do you think it wouldn't be done
to crops or kill too many of these guys
as it is haha I'm a winner you're a
loser oh my god oh my god how'd you get
over there no no no no no no whoa okay
alright this be
I think becomes ah ha ha he hockey huh
boy oh oh whoa oh oh wow oh god they got
me good
I didn't know that was gonna happen that
way I'm on the dinner plate today those
jobs again WP oh yeah
no no no no
Oh goddamnit okuni faster Enoch the
brick in my path it ruined all my no
that are completely given evidence by
baby turbo let it slide flips weirdest
way I'm a sneaky peeky Logan ego sham it
in there for almost got me but you
didn't because you sucks hobble big boo
boom b-b-boom gravity if you suck a lot
I'm the winner winner winner baby and
here I go like my song baby shimmy sham
okay fine then I guess my stop oh
because I stopped singing my song isn't
it because I stopped singing isn't it oh
I'm so P ah
this time I'm a real slippery random
game then we're gonna give me this time
okay this time I didn't real how many
times I've fallen off a linear path like
that that seems like a particularly
sticky one shouldn't have soaked up
before I went through there oh and
that's an achievement for the kitchen so
we are blazing a trail here and
unfortunately that is open that is all
the time that I have for this episode so
thank you everybody so much for watching
hope you're enjoying it thus far I know
I am so let me know what you think down
the comments below and as always I will
see you in the next video bye bye
[Music]